chuck schumer responding to comments uh
made by
mitch mcconnell in a radio interview a
few days ago where he entertained the
possibility that states in real duress
could always
file for bankruptcy the senator joins us
right now
on the phone mitch mcconnell very good
to have you what do you think of what
chuck schumer said this isn't being
wasted this is going to those directly
impacted by the coronavirus what do you
say
well we're certainly open to considering
additional
assistance to state and local
governments on top of what we've already
done and the karez act it is important
however to understand that
many states have systemic
long-standing challenges
many of them their pensions fund any of
them from overspending
so what we're saying here is
we're not interested in rescuing badly
run states from the mistakes they've
made
completely unrelated to the coronavirus
so let me make it perfectly clear we are
open to considering
another bill but my red line and going
forward on this bill is we need to
provide
protection litigation protection
for those who've been on the front line
hospitals doctors nurses
and imagine you're a businessman
thinking about reopening
and you've heard that the trial lawyers
all over the country are sharpening
their pencils
getting ready to sue you claiming that
you didn't
engage in proper distancing or other
issues related to health and safety look
we can't pass another bill
unless we have liability protection and
that's the only way we're going to
ultimately begin to get past this and
that is to begin to open up
the economy again we have to have
businesses brave enough to open up again
uh employees uh brave enough to go back
to work
and i'm glad to see that some of the
states are beginning
to move in the direction of reopening
all right but uh you're already your
idea maybe it was
just something you threw out there that
tort reform could be part
of more aid to the states nancy pelosi
responded that democrats are not
interested in cobit 19 tort reform the
house has no interest in diminishing
protections for employees and customers
um what do you say to that well let me
make it perfectly
clear the senate is not interested in
passing a bill that does not have
liability protection
so that's an integral part of our
economy getting back
uh to normal so uh
we're going back to work the senate's
coming back next monday
we're perfectly willing to discuss the
way forward but the way you make a law
it has to pass the house and the senate
what i'm saying is
we have a red line on liability it won't
pass the senate
without it so what would happen though
senator of a business feeling that it is
emboldened
uh by my liability protection
that it doesn't do some basic things
like masks and other protections for
workers
because it might feel that it's legally
bulletproof and doesn't have to
well it's a good question i mean you
have to carefully craft the liability
protection
to deal with the money that would be
supplied to state and local government
conditioned upon them and acting
at the state level the kind of
legislation that would provide liability
protection for those
who are seeking uh to go forward and to
get the economy
back up to work uh look male i've been
talking to
business people all over the country
there's a good deal of
fear about getting back to normal
knowing full well
the lawsuit that are awaiting unless we
address this issue
so this is an integral part of getting
the economy back up and running getting
the country back
up and running and that will be a
condition
for providing additional assistance to
state and local government
um let me ask you senator uh you made
some news in this access report i'm sure
you've heard about where you said we
need to keep the white house
democrats in a box both need to get the
message
you were referring to infrastructure the
president animated today
uh at a small business conference that
he was still open to that
pooh-poohed the notion that maybe you
two are in disagreement
so maybe i can get some clarity from you
are you
open and would you agree to
infrastructure spending as part of a
futures
you know stimulus relief plan
well we have an equal interest in doing
a
infrastructure bill we don't have an
equal interest in borrowing money for
future generations to pay for in other
words it's unrelated
to the coronavirus
pandemic which is the reason we have run
up the national debt 2.8
trillion dollars so i agree with the
president infrastructure is important
i just don't believe that we should be
borrowing adding to the national debt
we've added 2.8 trillion dollars to the
national debt
in the last month i just don't think
that's the path
to getting an infrastructure bill i do
agree with him that we need to do that
we're going to pass a more modest
infrastructure bill in the senate
in the in the near future since we're
coming back to work
next monday
but just to be clear as far as the next
round of stimulus you do not want it to
be
infrastructure am i getting that right
yeah i'll be clear that
infrastructure is unrelated uh to the
coronavirus
uh endemic that we're all experiencing
and trying to figure out how to go
forward
we've borrowed an incredible amount of
money here over the last
month and we need to
make sure that whatever additional
legislation we do is directly related
to this pandemic and to try to get it in
the rearview mirror and get the country
back
up and running again
senator while i have you here you made
up an interesting comment when you were
talking to
our guy benson on fox news radio in
which you were describing maybe some of
the problems around
the president of the healthcare task
force briefings in which you said
american people are most interested
in the advice from the health
professionals about how to conduct
their lives safely were you saying
that the president shouldn't talk as
much
no i wasn't saying that but i think
the american people are interested in
what
our health experts have to say about
this
pandemic we've never had this particular
disease before
they're anxious to get information about
how to conduct their lives consistently
with the recommendations so we can
safely go about
our business uh one of the reasons we
put
25 billion dollars in the additional
bill over and above the carriage bill
that we passed last week
for testing is we're not there yet
on testing not only what kind of tests
but how many of them
actually will tell you something other
than
you don't have it at the moment and we
don't yet have
a treatment and we don't yet have a
vaccine so we
allocated 25 billion dollars
at that whole area of testing
and treatment
and vaccine in the bill that we just
passed last week
that's all part of reassuring everyone
that they can safely go back to work
so i guess what i'm asking without
believing the point sir is that whether
you wanted to restructure the briefings
as they are
now you said to the extent that the
white house decides to recraft these
briefings to reflect
that goal referring to the medical
information you want to hear from the
experts
that is probably a good idea did that
mean that
either the briefing should be shorter
the healthcare task force members
only dr fauci dr burke that sort of
thing or what specifically would be most
beneficial do you think
to the american people
yeah i don't i don't have any advice to
give the white house about how to handle
the briefings i don't have any advice to
give them at all
so you were not meaning to imply
that these any comments apart from the
medical experts
were were not necessary
no i wasn't i did think that the medical
experts
are the one the public is the most
interested in for obvious reasons
because they're interested in how they
can
go about their business safely
finally senator the president talks
about a v-shaped recovery out of this
it's going to be tough especially given
the
stagger nature of opening up are you
worried that that's going to be tough
there will be
you know an economic pickup as people
get back but it might not
last it might take a while to get going
are you in
the camp that it's going to be a sharp
increase or a slow one
honestly neil i don't know i i think we
we're in a place we've never been before
we're all hoping for a more rapid
recovery
i think we get a more rapid recovery if
we have liability reform
if we have testing that reassures people
because the economy won't truly be open
unless everybody's willing to
participate in the economy once again so
i'm not an expert on these things and we
have
uh this is an experience we haven't had
before so
it's hard to figure out what may happen
yeah as we
uh move ahead but we do know we need to
move ahead and i'm pleased that
a number of states are beginning to move
in the direction of opening up the
economy
uh consistent with the phase one
recommendations of the white house
uh uh there you go coronavirus task
force
we shall see all right mitch mcconnell
thank you very much